>>> GOLAWMAKERS ARE PRIVATELY
TELLING CNN THAT THEY ARE
STUNNED BY TUESDAY'S BOMB SHELL
TESTIMONY FROM FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE AIDE CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON.
>> ONE SENIOR HOUSE REPUBLICAN
WHO VOTED AGAINST IMPEACHMENT
PREDICTS THIS EVIDENCE WAS SO
DAMAGING THAT IT COULD LEAD TO
INDICTMENTS FOR TRUMP AND/OR HIS
ALLIES.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JOE WALSH
OF ILLINOIS.
HE'S THE HOST OF THE WHITE FLAG
PODCAST AND RENA SHAW, SHE'S A
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST AND A
SENIOR ADVISER FOR THE
REPUBLICAN WOMEN FOR PROGRESS.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
ALWAYS A QUESTION OF WHAT WILL
MOVE THE NEEDLE WITH, YOU KNOW,
TRUMP'S VERY, VERY DEVOTED BASE
AND THERE WAS ONE DATA POINT
THAT I FOUND INTERESTING TODAY,
AND THAT WAS "THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER," THIS CONSERVATIVE
OUTLET AS YOU KNOW.
IT HAS ALL SORTS OF WELL-KNOWN
CONTRIBUTORS THAT APPEAR ON FOX
REGULARLY, AND HERE WAS THEIR
EDITORIAL TODAY.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE AIDE CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON'S TUESDAY TESTIMONY
OUGHT TO RING THE DEATH KNELL
FOR FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S POLITICAL CAREER.
TRUMP IS UNFIT TO BE ANYWHERE
NEAR POWER EVER AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK CHANGED
YESTERDAY, IF ANYTHING?
>> ALISYN, I THINK IT'S
CUMULATIVE.
I THINK THESE HEARINGS ARE
HURTING TRUMP.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DEEP AND FOR
HOW LONG, AND I'D REMIND
EVERYBODY IN THE WEEK AFTER
JANUARY 6th, I'M IN A UNIQUE
POSITION BECAUSE I HEAR FROM
THAT DEVOTED TRUMP BASE EVERY
DAY, AND IN THE WEEK AFTER
JANUARY 6th EVEN TRUMP'S MOST
DEVOTED BASE WAS BACK ON THEIR
HEELS, AND THEY WERE
DISAPPOINTED AND ANGRY AND
QUESTIONING TRUMP, AND THEN OVER
TIME THAT WAS ALL CORRECTED.
THE OTHER THING, ALISYN, THAT
I'M HEARING IS FROM HIS DEVOTED
BASE THEY'RE NOT DISAPPOINTED IN
HIS BEHAVIOR THAT'S COMING OUT
DURING THESE HEARINGS.
WHAT THEY'RE TELLING ME IS, OH,
ALL OF THIS STUFF IS GOING TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR TRUMP TO WIN
IN 2024.
THAT'S, I THINK, WHAT'S MOVING
THEM FOR NOW AWAY FROM TRUMP.
>> NOW, THAT'S THE BASE.
RENA, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
WHO, AS WE SAID AT THE TOP ARE
PRIVATELY STUNNED.
THEY'RE GOBSMACKED IN THEIR
OFFICES BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING?
DID YOU HEAR ANYTHING THAT WOULD
SUGGEST, RENA, THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO COME OUT AND PUT SOME
NAMES BEHIND THIS ASTONISHMENT?
>> LOOK, IT'S NOT A SMALL THAT I
THINK -- THING THAT MICK
MULVANEY CAME OUT IN SUPPORT OF
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON.
HE DOESN'T THINK SHE'S LYING.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
THIS YOUNG WOMAN WHO'S NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO 30.
THEY KNOW SHE HAS NO REASON TO
LIE ABOUT WHAT SHE SAW.
SHE WAS PART OF THE HEARTBEAT OF
THE WEST WING, AND I'M OF COURSE
NO STRANGER TO THAT KIND OF
THING.
I REMEMBER ON CAPITOL HILL
WORKING FOR TWO DIFFERENT
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
SHARING SENTIMENTS LIKE THAT
WHEN I WAS FRUSTRATED.
ONE BIG LINE SHE SAID WHICH KIND
OF STRUCK ME WAS HE NEEDS TO
CARE, AND SHE WAS OF COURSE
TALKING ABOUT HER DIRECT BOSS,
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS.
THE REALITY IS THIS.
WHETHER OR NOT IT MOVES THE
NEEDLE WITH TRUMP SUPPORTERS OR
NOT IS NOT THE QUESTION HERE.
IT'S WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE START
TO BACK CANDIDATES LIKE GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS WITH MORE SORT OF
ENTHUSIASM, THE LONG-TIME
SENTIMENT IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS BEEN A LOVE FOR OUR
GOVERNORS, OF COURSE, THOSE WHO
GET THINGS DONE.
AND NOW WITH THIS PICTURE OF AN
UNHINGED TRUMP IT BOLSTERS THE
IMAGE.
IT HELPS TOO THAT TRUMP ENDORSED
CANDIDATES ARE LOSING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THERE'S TWO THINGS AT PLAY HERE.
>> THAT LEADS US TO SEAN
HANNITY, JOE, HE'S CONFUSING
BECAUSE THE TEXTS THAT HAVE COME
OUT.
I MEAN, HONESTLY DURING THE
HEARINGS SHOW THAT HE WAS VERY
WORRIED IN THE DAYS BEFORE
JANUARY 6th.
HE SAW THE STORM CLOUD, YOU
KNOW, GATHERING, AND SO HE WAS
SENDING TEXTS TO MARK MEADOWS,
I'M VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE NEXT
48 HOURS, AND THEN LAST NIGHT
HE'S JUST BACK ON THE SLAVISH
TRUMP TRAIN.
I'LL JUST PLAY A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT HE WAS TRYING TO SAY ABOUT
HOW THERE'S NOTHING TO SEE HERE
AT THESE HEARINGS.
>> THEY WERE BUSY WITH YET
ANOTHER ANTI-TRUMP KANGAROO
COURT AND SHOW TRIAL WHERE THE
OUTCOME, AS WE'VE BEEN TELLING
YOU HAS BEEN AND REMAINS
PREDETERMINED.
WE SEE NOTHING BUT BLIND, NEVER
ENDING RAGE, WHAT IS SEEMINGLY
AN OBSESSIVE-COMPULSIVE CULT
LIKE RAGE AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
>> JOE, DOESN'T SEAN WANT TO
PIVOT TO A WINNER AT SOME POINT?
>> ALISYN, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
THERE'S NOTHING CONFUSING ABOUT
SEAN HANNITY.
LOOK, HE'S A FRAUD, AND HE IS A
TRUMP CHEERLEADER, AND HE'LL BE
THAT WAY -- I MEAN, ALISYN,
HANNITY WOULD BE THE LAST PERSON
ON THE TRUMP BOAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT JUST DRIVES
ME CRAZY, AND VICTOR, YOU NAILED
IT, THESE REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHO ARE PRIVATELY
STUNNED, PRIVATELY.
I'M SO SICK OF THE PRIVATELY.
I THINK MOST OF THEM, ALISYN,
WILL MOVE TO A WINNER, BUT WE'RE
NOWHERE NEAR THAT YET.
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL THE
PROHIBITIVE NOMINEE OF THIS
PARTY.
>> RENA, I WANT TO TOUCH ON
SOMETHING YOU MENTIONED THERE
ABOUT TRYING TO GET MARK MEADOWS
TO CARE.
REPEATEDLY HUTCHINSON DESCRIBED
MARK MEADOWS SITTING ON HIS SOFA
SCROLLING ON HIS PHONE AT SOME
OF THE CRUCIAL MOMENTS LEADING
UP TO AND THROUGH THE
INSURRECTION.
LET'S WATCH PART OF THE
TESTIMONY.
>> I REMEMBER HIM BEING ALONE IN
HIS OFFICE FOR MOST OF THE
AFTERNOON.
AROUND 2:00 TO 2:05, AROUND 2:00
TO 2:05, YOU KNOW, WE WERE
WATCHING THE TV AND I COULD SEE
THAT THE RIOTERS WERE GETTING
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THE
CAPITOL.
MARK STILL HADN'T POPPED OUT OF
HIS OFFICE OR SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
WATCHING THE TV, CHIEF?
AND HE'S LIKE, YEAH.
THE RIOTERS ARE GETTING REALLY
CLOSE.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THE
PRESIDENT?
HE SAID, NO, HE WANTS TO BE
ALONE RIGHT NOW.
AND I JUST REMEMBER -- I
REMEMBER THINKING IN THAT MOMENT
MARK NEEDS TO SNAP OUT OF THIS,
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO SNAP HIM
OUT OF THIS, BUT HE NEEDS TO
CARE.
>> HE NEEDS TO CARE.
REALLY A DEVASTATING PORTRAIT
THAT SHE PAINTED THERE OF THE
CHIEF OF STAFF JUST SCROLLING ON
HIS PHONE AS THERE ARE RIOTERS
APPROACHING THE CAPITOL.
>> YEAH, THE CHIEF OF STAFF TO
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WAS SO VERY PASSE ABOUT
ONE OF HIS BROS IN CONGRESS,
MIKE PENCE.
I REMEMBER WATCHING THE TWO OF
THEM HOW THEY GOT ALONG WHEN
THEY SERVED TOGETHER THERE, HOW
THEY GOT ALONG SO WELL, AND HERE
HE WAS.
THEY WERE CALLING FOR MIKE PENCE
TO BE HUNG, AND MARK MEADOWS
JUST DOES NOT CARE IT SEEMS.
SO LOOK, THAT'S FRUSTRATING, BUT
THE BIG PICTURE HERE IS THAT
DEMOCRACY'S FRAGILE, AND IT
TAKES PRINCIPLED GOOD PEOPLE
WITH GOOD MORALS AND VALUES TO
SAY SOMETHING'S WRONG HERE.
THEY SHOULD BE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ABLE TO DECIPHER BETWEEN
RIGHT AND WRONG.
SADLY IN THIS CASE IT WAS A
WOMAN SO YOUNG AND NOT OLDER,
MORE EXPERIENCED PEOPLE.
BUT LISTEN, THE REALITY IS THAT
TRUMPISM CAN BE DEFEATED AND I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T AGREE
WITH ME, BUT AS LONG AS FEAR AND
DIVISION, AND DEMONIZING THE
DEMOCRAT S IS A PLAYBOOK OF THE
REPUBLICANS, WHICH IT WILL BE
FOR A VERY LONG TIME, MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE WILL START TO
UNDERSTAND THAT'S NOT THE
AMERICAN WAY.
ALREADY LAST NIGHT WE SAW JOHN
CURTIS AND BLAKE MOORE TWO
CANDIDATES THAT WON PRIMARIES
AND THEY BOTH VOTED FOR THE
JANUARY 6th SELECT COMMITTEE.
THAT TELLS ME AGAIN TRUMPISM CAN
BE DEFEATED.
MAYBE NOT NEXT HOUR, MAYBE NOT
TOMORROW, BUT DOWN THE LINE IT